MySQL is one of the most popular databases,
learn how to use it in this course from a
senior database engineer. Welcome to this
basic MySQL course I want to start by appreciating
you for trying to learn a new skill. Let me
introduce myself. My name is Barbara and I
work for Salesforce as a senior database engineer,
I have over 12 years of experience with a
variety of databases Oracle being the main
one, I have experience working with companies
like Chase, PayPal, Wells, Fargo, StubHub,
etc. Let me answer a few basic questions for
you first, and that is who, what and why.
So who should take this course this course
is meant for database professionals who want
to expand their skill set. If you are a software
engineer or a full stack developer and you
want to gain a deep understanding of MySQL
database, this course is for you. And if you're
a college student, or a computer science student
or a fresh graduate, this course will give
you some knowledge on database internals.
So why should you learn MySQL, MySQL is the
most popular open source database and of course,
Postgres. SQL is definitely up there. As companies
move their data from on prem to cloud, they
usually like migrate to a cloud native database,
or an open source database, like MySQL or
Postgres sequel, in order to save costs. So
let's say that you are an Oracle Database
expert. If you gain knowledge on a database
like MySQL, then you could help companies
migrate their data from Oracle to MySQL, and
that can be really valuable. Now let's look
at what is being covered in this course. Now,
first of all, by MySQL, I mean, the MySQL
InnoDB storage engine throughout this course,
which is used behind any commerce website,
or a bank or a financial institution, and
so on. And MySQL offers a variety of storage
engines, my I Sam, in memory storage engine,
or some popular storage engines, which are
available, we are going to learn about MySQL
InnoDB, I am not covering any other type of
storage engines. Now, these are the topics
that I'm going to cover in this course. And
please note that this is a database administration
course. So it is 80% database administration.
And for people who are completely new to databases,
I have included SQL basics. So you'll be learning
about database installation, MySQL Workbench,
database indexes, database logs, you'll also
learn a little bit of performance tuning,
that is SQL explain. So these are some interesting
topics that I'm going to cover. So what do
you exactly need to get started with this
course, you need a PC or a Mac. So if you're
using a PC, then I recommend you to actually
look into the worksheets or supplemental material
that is attached in the description. If you
have a Mac laptop, then you are in the best
position to learn this course. Because then
you can just see what I'm typing. And you
can just type the same commands and just follow
along from end to end. And most of all, this
is the main requirement, I want you to create
an AWS account, that's correct and amaze on
Web Services account. So if you don't know
what I'm talking about, please do look into
my worksheet which can be found in the description,
I've attached some resources, which will show
you how to create an AWS account, I will be
using an AWS EC two instance throughout the
course. And I'll show you how to create one.
But one main thing that I want you to remember
is after each study session of yours, you
can shut down your EC two instance. That way
you don't have to pay any unnecessary cost.
And please do remember that you don't have
to keep your EC two instance running 24 seven.
So once you have created an AWS account, and
sign in, you will land on this dashboard,
or this page. And you can go to the services
menu right here. And then under compute, you
can choose easy to so over here on the left
hand side, you can choose instances. And then
here we're going to create an instance which
will be our lab environment. So click on launch
instance. And then let's choose an image for
our instance. So I'm going to choose Red Hat
Enterprise Linux version 864 bit and my instance
type is going to be T two micro which is free
tier eligible. And you need to choose an appropriate
subnet. If you just created an AWS account,
you can just leave. Leave it whatever default
subnet that shows up for you. For me, I'm
going to choose me Be a specific one. And
then make sure to enable this auto assign
public IP option. Because that will assign
a public IP to your instance using which you
can SSH into your instance, from your laptop,
and leave all the other settings as is. And
let's allocate like 25 gigs, for the database,
or for the entire instance. And you can just
leave the rest ISIS, go to the next page read,
you can create a tag for your instance. So
I'm gonna call it my SQL instance. One, go
to the security group page. And then here,
what's important is that you need to be able
to SSH into the instance. And you need to,
you need to create proper firewall rules for
that anyone, basically, anyone in the world
can log into this instance, via Port 22. And
that's not secure at all. And I will take
care of this instance. Because once I finished
recording, I usually remove it. So I know
how to handle this. But when you create rules,
make sure to put your laptop's IP in there,
just so it's more secure, then now you can
review your configuration, and then click
on launch. But if you want, you can create
a new key pair, and then just give it some
name. And then download it before you create
the instance. For me, I'm just going to choose
an existing key pair. Maybe this one, and
I say knowledge, maybe a different one. All
right, this one. And launch instance. Now
your instance is getting created, it probably
take a couple of minutes to create this instance.
Okay, that's how you create an EC two instance.
And now that my instance is up and running,
and I can see the public IP. Later, I will
be installing MySQL on this instance. So that's
what I wanted to show you in this lesson.
So what you're seeing is basically my sequel
documentation showing all these different
installation guides, like Windows and Mac,
and so on. So we are interested in Linux installation
are basically MySQL installation on Linux.
And there's a couple of guides actually. So
this one is basically installing jannettek
binary, we're gonna skip that and go here.
And even within installing MySQL, on Linux,
there's a bunch of guides. So the recommended
method of installation is using RPM packages
from Oracle. But we're going to use this MySQL
yum repository based installation. And it's
actually quite straightforward. So for this
installation, we need to go to MySQL comm
and downloads. And we are downloading the
Community Edition and go to yum repository.
As you know, the instance that we created
has Archie l eight, Red Hat, Enterprise Linux
eight running on it. And so we need to download
this rpm. But then we need to download the
RPM on the instance itself, the one that we
created. So let's actually log into the instance.
So I'm going to use SSH, and we're going to
use my private key. And logging is easy to
user choose the default user and basically
get the public IP of my instance login and
we switch to a root okay. So one thing that
we need for downloading this RPM to this Linux
instance is W get package. So let's go ahead
and install that first. Alright, so now that
w gate is installed, we need to download the
RPM that we just saw. So to get the link of
this RPM, we need to go into this download.
And we have to right click here and copy the
link. And if you're installing on a different
OSS, you need to click on the appropriate
button. Okay, so we got the link, and let's
just go ahead and paste that link over here,
like w get and the link. And that command
downloads this package, now we are going to
use an RPM command to install this package.
So this package, as I mentioned before, is
going to add this MySQL yum repo to your local
system repo list. With Red Hat Enterprise
Linux installation, you get like a MySQL module
by default. So let's disable that one. If
you don't disable it, then this will interfere
with our MySQL installation. So let's go ahead
and disable it using this command. And don't
worry about writing these commands, I will
put a link to my Git repo with all these comments
in the description. So all these have been
disabled. Now let's go ahead and install MySQL
community Server Edition using yum install
MySQL community server. And let's put minus
y in there just to go ahead and accept all
the prompts. And that's installing all these
packages. Alright, so my SQL has been installed.
Let's go ahead and start the MySQL database
using system CTL. Command. And let's check
the status. So now, my SQL database is up
and running. Okay, so the log file of this
MySQL database software is under var log.
And then if you grip temp from this log file,
you will get the temporary password for root
user. And you can use that to log into the
MySQL database. And how do you log in, you
use this command my sequel minus u, that's
going to be root and minus P is for password
based login. And then we're logging into MySQL
database. So let's use this password and see
if it logs in. And we are in. And if you run
any command at this point, my sequel is going
to ask you to reset the password using alter
user statement. We can do this in a different
way. So there is a executable called MySQL
admin. And this is the command for it. MySQL
admin, minus you the user name and minus p
password. We are going to reset the password
of root user. And let's provide the current
password which is this temporary password
first. And let's provide the new password
No. All right, the password has been accepted.
Now let me try to log in with this new password
using the previous command my SQL minus u
proved and minus p MySQL. Let me put the password
I said just now we are in. So let's go ahead
and run a simple show databases command which
shows all the default databases that come
as part of the installation. So one more thing
that we need to do to complete the installation
is to load a timezone file or timezone table
as shown here. So if I do a select star, which
is basically a SQL query to read from this
table, you can see that the table is empty
right now. So let's exit out and run another
command. To load timezone related data. So
this is the command. And let's go ahead and
run it. And I'm going to go ahead and put
my password, and that loads a bunch of data,
you can ignore all these warnings. Let's go
back to our MySQL database. So if you do as
select star, from MySQL dot timezone, again,
it shows a bunch of data. So now, you're good.
And that completes the MySQL database installation.
Alright, folks, in this section, we are going
to talk about data modeling. Okay, so database
design, data modeling, schema design, these
are all interchangeable words, terms for database
design is an ongoing process. So you come
up with a basic design, when you sort of like
create your application. And then as the application,
you know, gets added new features, enhancements,
improvements, you basically iterate over this
design, right, you keep adding new things
to your design, and so on. So the first thing
that you do when you're doing database design
or data modeling is understand business data.
And then once you understand business data,
you have to come up with logical design of
your database. What do I mean by that? Well,
basically, you have to design your tables,
the columns, that goes into those tables,
indexes, constraints, like primary key constraint,
unique key constraint, not null constraints,
default values, foreign keys, these are all
various things that you need to create. When
you when you come up with a logical design
of your schema, once you actually have this
basic table design or schema design, then
you can look for data redundancy, that is
basically you see where your data is repetative.
And then you start eliminating it by normalizing
your tables actually. And that's because data
redundancy causes data anomalies. What I mean
by that is, when you have like multiple occurrences
of the same data, when you're, let's say,
updating certain data, you have to update
in many places. And if you forget to update
even one place, now you you have two versions
of the same data in your database. And that
creates like data anomaly data inconsistency
is along the same lines actually. And all
that happens because of data redundancy. So
what we are looking at is basically a spreadsheet
and the spreadsheet is basically a huge table
a large table, right? And, and what what we
are going to do is basically design a table
for a ecommerce website, an e commerce website
is basically like an amazing zone, or E Bay,
or whatever, like online business, like online
e commerce website, like Alibaba, or whatever,
right? Let's say like, you have only one table
in this database, right? And you start, as
the orders come in, through this website,
you start putting data into this table, right?
You have, you know, let's look at some of
the things that you will record in this table,
right, you obviously need like a count of
your orders. So you might like numbering your
orders, and then how it is coming like, you
know, is it desktop or mobile? Or what product
is it? Like, you know, here I have got like
a couple of books, the book titles, and then
the price of the products. And then who is
the customer customers details, payment details,
delivery details, and so on. So these are
all part of like, e commerce word, basically.
Right? And you have one giant table. And if
you look at the data here, right? So, you
know, here, I've got like a couple of customers
buying you know, sort of like two different
product products, right. So, and you can see
that the data has been repetitive. What I
mean by that is like every time I buy the
same product, I have to repeat this data,
like the first order that came in was through
the web desktop website that was brought by
birth and then you can see all the details
of this customer and all that details about
the product and the payment, payment details
as well. Then the second order that came was
from a different person, but then it was,
you know, the order was for the same product
and you had to repeat the product information.
Right. The third was from the previous customer.
But then this time he bought bought a different
product, his information, the customer information
has repeated actually. So there is a lot of
data redundancy data has been repetative.
So, this is basically a denormalized database,
where you have only one table or a handful
of tables, we back all the information from
your website, or your business into these
few tables. Actually, this is a denormalized
version of your database, let's actually go
look at what else you could do. So what you
can do is basically, you can start with this
basic denormalize table, and then you can
start taking out all the redundant information
out of your database or your table action,
it first thing I did was I took out like the
customer information, they put it in a separate
table, right. And I've got only customer details
here. And I started like putting a ID number
for each customer ID or customer number, whatever
you call it. Once I take out the customer
information, I have the Orders table, the
initial table, I'm calling Orders table looking
like this now, right? And you can see that
I've got like customer ID column over here.
And what is this customer ID column? Your
guesses? Right? So this customer ID column
is the same as what you see over here. Right?
So and why do I have that because I need a
way to relate these rows. As you can tell,
like, you know, these are columns, these are
rows, these rows, I need to be able to relate
to a customer, right? If I take out customer
information, then how can I relate? You know,
this table and that table? It's through a
common column, or a bunch of columns. Actually,
in this case, it's just one column. So customer
ID, right? I'm just like putting the ID number
over here. And what else actually we can take
out of this table. So this is one level of
normalization. Right? So let's keep normalizing
which is like take out the product details.
Right? So product details are also repeating.
So here, you don't feel that much pain, because
there's only three records in this table.
What if the table has million records, right?
This is why we need to normalize the table.
Now you actually take out the product information
and move it to a different table. And then
I have a product ID column just to number,
like ID the products actually, and your Orders
table will look like this, then you take out
the payment information to a different table.
And your Orders table will then look like
this. This is basically the process of going
from a denormalized schema or a database to
a normalized database. When you have your
data in a single table, then you don't need
to do any joints. So you might ask actually,
what are joints actually, when you're running
queries, like using SQL, SQL is a language
right? A Structured Query Language, when you're
running commands in your database, you, you
can get all your data from this one table
if your table database is totally denormalized.
Whereas if you have many tables, you need
to sort of combine or join the stables and
then you have to get the data out. So that
is called joining the tables. So when you
have a denormalize database, you don't have
to do many joints. And that is kind of good
in a way because your database doesn't have
to think that much to get the data. You say
I want this data and this data is available
in this table. So it's just very straightforward.
Whereas like in a in a normalized database,
when you join many tables, then your database
engine with which they call optimizer in,
in Oracle or in most of the tape most of the
databases. So this database engine has to
think more as then like, okay, which table
Should I scan first? And how should I filter
the data in this table. And then Okay, I take
the result set from that table and have to
join with these other tables. So there is
so much more thinking there's so much more
processing that has to happen on whichever
server this database is running on. Right.
And because of that, the performance will
be kind of flexible. Lower right and it will
consume a lot of resources and you have all
that happening at scale as in like many operations
are happening at the same time, then you basically
have slow performance actually, or at least
lower than what it would have been in a denormalize
database, but at the same time, we are removing
so much data repetition or data redundancy
is very low, because of that, the storage
needed in a normalized database is much lower.
So, you cannot actually like generalize and
say a normalized database will always be slow
or denormalize database will be fast, it is
all like it depends actually you have to look
at the data and see how much repetition is
happening, etc, etc. So, but generally this
is how it goes, as you go through this design
process, right, you know, see what we have
done actually, right. So, we have decided,
the tables that we need, like you know, we
have orders, table products got the customers
and payments, and we decide the column names.
And then not just that for each table, you
need to decide actually what will be the primary
key. What I mean by that as a primary key
is a unique key and which cannot be null,
actually, which is very important. So using
this primary key, you should be able to identify
any record in this table, any row in this
table. For example, if I say here, the primary
key is order number, then I can, anytime if
I have an order number, then I can look up
this table, let's say order number equals
two, I can just get this record out of my
database. And then you need to also have like
some unique keys actually, right. So unique
keys is pretty much like primary key. And
a unique key can be now a primary key cannot
be null, as I mentioned. And then you can
also have indexes on your table. So indexes
are ways to basically select your day data
faster. Let's say that I often search this
table based on a customer's email, then I
need an index on customer email column, right,
you need to decide that. And you need to decide
about which columns can be null. Right? Here,
none of the columns can be null. Let's say
you have another column called preference
a the customer preference as in what kind
of shipping or what kind of or which phone
number is preferred, or something like that.
So that can be a null column, right? So you
can have none columns. Otherwise, you define
your columns as not null. Let's say like,
in your Orders table, you have this delivered
column, when an order is basically created
when a customer buys a product on your website.
Of course, it's not delivered immediately,
at the time of order creation, the delivered
column will always have no or n, a n value,
right? All these things, all these decisions
that we are making we're talking about is
part of schema design. And once you have all
this figured out, you can put the information
in your design tool Entity Relationship design
tool. And in the next section, I will show
you how I do that on sequel workbench, my
sequel world workbench, basically, you can
actually then have a pictorial representation
of your logical design of your database, right.
And that's basically what you call an ER diagram.
And of course, you can talk about the relationship
between the two tables, let's say you can
say oh, this table in this table, they have
one to many relationship, for example, each
customer can place many orders. So that is
actually a one to many relationship, right.
But one, you know, one order can be done by
only one customer. Right? So, so that kind
of thing. So you have one to one relationship,
one to many relationship, or many to many
relationship between tables. Actually, these
are all part of data modeling. But you don't
need to be worried so much about that, as
long as you have a clear idea of like what
data is coming into your database. And along
the way, you need to define like the data
type of your columns. Actually, that is very
important. Your names are going to be a wild
char. You know, phone numbers can be numbers,
and then email is again like a watch chart.
And your ID column or number columns are going
to be int or number. These are all some decisions
that you would make you In a data modeling
task, actually, that's pretty much what I
want to say about data modeling, then there's
much more we can talk about it. And like atomicity,
like you, you have all the address, sort of
like attributes packed into one column, we,
we need to split that as well. So that is
called atomicity. You can have address separately,
city separately states separately, and, you
know, zip code separately, right. So those
kinds of things, there are nuances that make
your database more and more efficient. And,
of course, we're not going to go into a lot
of details there. But this is the basic data
modeling that you need to understand. And
as I said before, in the next section, I will
show you how to take this and then input that
on my sequel workbench. quick recap of what
I did in the last section, I basically created
a logical design of an e commerce website.
So what you're looking at is a table that
I started with. It's a denormalize table,
and we basically took this denormalized table,
and we normalized it. As you can see, there
is four versions of this table, I'm calling
this table Orders table. So there is four
different versions. And I with each iteration,
I took out repeating data. So finally, we
landed with four tables, apart from the original
Orders table. So now we have also customers
products and payment. In this video, I'm going
to take this now all the stables and then
I'm going to take the structure, and I am
going to create a logical design. Okay, so
let's actually go to MySQL Workbench and I
am already connected to a database, what I
am going to do is go to File and go to new
models. so here we can add a new ER diagram,
an entity relationship diagram. And let's
call this database eecom. Store, something
like that. So let's go ahead and start creating
our tables. Now, I'm not going to be creating
all four tables that would take probably more
time or long, and I'm going to be creating
a couple of tables. And that should be enough
for you to understand how we're doing this.
So let's just start with the Customers table.
So the customer table has five columns, this
is the icon for creating a new table, you
can drag and drop, or you can try to draw
now double click and then create a table called
customer and here we can start putting the
table the column names customer ID, and then
this is going to be populated by your sequence.
So sequence is a database object. And it's
going to be an integer. So we can leave it
as is. And we can have it as a primary key,
that's fine and a primary key has to be populated,
it cannot be now. So that is automatically
selected. The next one is customer name, we
could split that into first name, and then
we can choose watch our and maybe give a little
bit more room as in the length of the name
and then last name, I can watch 100 and then
all these cannot be now so we can choose not
null constraint. So these are different constraints
which are available. Let's go ahead with the
next one address again address. And if you
remember I talked about atomicity. So you
want your columns to be you know, atomic in,
in the sense that here, basically the whole
address is packed into one column. good practice
to actually split that into atomic columns
as an address separately, city separately
state separately and then zip code separately.
So we have all these, of course, none of these
can be now and what else is there? So customer
phone number, phone number is going to be
all numbers. But then I want to make get 10
numbers, of course not null and customer email.
So I can just say email id 100 Okay, not null.
So since I Id is the primary key here or customer
ID, I want to make sure that that we have
a constraint to avoid repeating customer information.
For example, if you have one customers data
for ID one, I don't want the same customer,
customers data to repeat for a different ID,
for example, Id two. So I'm gonna actually
make email id unique for each record over
here. And then may or may be phone number
also. So these are all unique key constraints,
or unique constraints. That's it. So we have
the Customers table created. So let's go back
and see what else we have. So let's now create,
I would say product. And then you basically
do the same thing, select that is for creating
a new table. And then now here, you can just
draw in this one, I'm going to call it product.
And we want to go through the same process
and then put the product column names in there.
If you're wondering, this is the same customer
ID column that we added over here. And we
are going to make that a foreign key in a
minute. So let's go ahead and split that into
multiple columns. Because, again, everything
is packed into one column, which is not a
good practice. So let's say let's call it
credit card number. If the customer is using
PayPal, then we need that email. So can use
email id over here. So this can be null or
not null based on what payment type is being
used. So that's okay, so expiration date is
going to be a date column. So let's actually
change that. So if you're not sure, you can
hit that the drop down and then choose your
proper data type for each. The other thing
that I mentioned, which is basically about
foreign key, this customer ID is the same
as what we added over here. So let's actually
make that customer ID a foreign key. So we
can just call it customer ID foreign key one.
And then the table that is going to be referenced
is the customers. And the column is going
to be customer ID. And that's it. So you can
see that now we have connection or a relation
between these two tables, I'm going to actually
just add the Orders table as well. I've created
the Orders table as well, which is the main
table and I'm going to now create some foreign
keys for the orders. Everything is done. If
you want to create any indexes at this point,
you can do that. So I guess we are done. So
we are basically added four tables to our
logical design these four tables and then
we have created columns and then define their
data types. And also we created the foreign
keys and of course primary key and unique
key for each of the tables. And you can see
the foreign key relationship you know clearly
showing here and that You know, that's what
you would do to create a data model. Alright,
so now actually, let's just go ahead and create
a SQL script for this data model. So you go
to database, and then do forward engineer.
And then basically, you provide the database
details where you want to create this, these
tables are the schema. So this is, these are
my details continue, go to the next one, provide
the password. Right now we are connected,
I had to try the password two, three times.
And this has basically created SQL script
for us to create the schema and the tables
with all the primary key unique key and foreign
key constraints. So what we can do is we can
just continue and then now the database or
the schema is created as it goes through and
then executes that script. And close. And
now you can see the stables are actually created.
So you can even go to your SQL editor, and
then you can start reading your can start
querying your tables. There you go. So you
ready came back, of course, there is no data
in it. And you can now start using your database.
So we actually successfully created the basic
schema, or designed the data model for this
e commerce website. Table creation or a CREATE
TABLE command starts with CREATE TABLE keyword
followed by the name of the table and followed
by parenthesis. So within the parenthesis,
this pair of parentheses, you have all these
column names, followed by the column data
types, and followed by the constraints. And
you can also use this auto increment keyword,
if you want your column value to be incremented.
Automatically, as you load values to the as
you load records to this table, and after
the column definition, you have the option
of specifying the keys like primary keys,
unique keys, foreign keys, and so on, you
can also specify the storage engine type as
part of your table creation. And this is a
very simple table. You can also have partition
tables or partition tables that have compressed
tables, encrypted tables, and all these things
require special keywords to be used in your
table definition. And please check my sequel
documentation. If you want more details about
the syntax. As mentioned, I'm using just integer
watch char data types, the MySQL documentation
shows like all these different data types
like numeric, date, and time data types, string
data types, like the ones I'm using, and JSON
spatial. So these are all available in MySQL
for you to use. So let's go ahead and create
this table. And before creating the table,
I want to run this drop command just to make
sure the table doesn't exist. And I'm going
to be creating that table and see if the table
has been created. Yes, the table has been
created successfully, I'm going to be running
a select star from the table name to see if
I can successfully query from this table as
well. And then it returns. Basically, it doesn't
return anything that means no data exists
in the stable. And that's how you create a
table using CREATE TABLE syntax. Finally,
there is actually a default keyword which
helps you specify default values for a certain
or for your columns. So if you don't specify
a value for this quantity column in your insert
statements, or when you're loading through
procedures, loading data through procedures,
it will automatically take this default value.
That's pretty much it. And I'll see you guys
in my next MySQL SQL session. So I just did
a describe on the table that I created and
it has product ID product name, product type,
price and quantity. And you can see that product
ID is also an auto incrementing column right
now there is no data in it a typical insert
Statement looks like this, let's go to insert
into keyword and the table name a bunch of
columns within parenthesis, the ones that
you want to populate, followed by the values
keyword. And followed by the actual column
values. If you can realize I haven't actually
specified the product ID value because it's
an auto incrementing column. So let's go ahead
and execute this and insert statement goes
through. So let me also run the select statement.
As you can see, the product ID table has taken
the value one, and that's happened automatically
ident supply the value one, so I'll go ahead
and commit the change. And then let's actually
move on to the second variation. So this time,
I'm going to specify a value for product ID,
nothing else is different. So just want to
show you that it is possible. So it goes through
and then a commit. And then let's do a select
to make sure the value has been inserted.
So let's go to this third variation of this
insert statement. So it's going to be pretty
much the same, except Actually, I'm going
to just jump some values and then insert the
value 10. For this product ID column, I'll
go ahead and do that. It goes through a comment
and select again, then you can see that that
is also fine. So yeah, so that worked. So
you can actually jump a few values. let's
actually look at the next variation. Again,
I'm going to insert a record into the stable,
with no product ID specified exclusively.
Or explicitly, the product ID column is missing
over here, and I'm going to run the insert
statement and commit. And then I'm going to
run the select statement. So just wanted to
show you that wherever the latest value is
for this auto incrementing column, I inserted
the value 10 for product ID last time, and
then the next time I do an insert is auto
increment kicks in and then you know increases,
increases this value from 10 to 11, right
picks up from the value that was inserted
last time. And I'm gonna just take another
insert statement, and this time, it's actually
insert into the table name. And instead of
the values keyword, specifying the column
names, values, etc, we actually select from
a different table. Basically, if the products
three table is exactly matching the structure
of products, one table, then we can do even
a select star from if the columns don't match
exactly as in like products, one has a different
set of columns, and product three has a different
set of columns, then we need to make sure
that we actually select the columns. And then,
for example, this product ID from products,
three maps to this product ID and products
one, and product name from products, three
maps to product one in I'm sorry, Product
Name and product one, and so on. Let's go
ahead and run this and see what happens. And
then that goes through. And then if I now
select the products, one table, you can see
like take all these rows are inserted properly.
And basically the products one table is populated.
And then we got all the data from products
three table. So this time I want to show you
the insert statement. Again, this is kind
of like a bulk insert or multiple insert just
combined into one statement, you can see the
insert into clause is specified only once
but in the values spark in this clause, actually,
we have two rows specified at the same time.
So we can even use such as syntax and a commit,
and then do a select all good. So these are
a few variations of insert statement. I hope
you understood how this works. I will see
you guys in the next session. Hey, my sequel
learners. So in this session, actually, I'm
going to be talking about update and delete
statements. So as usual, I'm going to be using
my eecom store schema. And I will be using
my products table to do this demo. So just
quickly, if we select products table, there's
two rows right now. So the first update is
just to show you the syntax of update. So
you have the update keyword followed by the
table name followed by set keyword. And then
you can have as many columns as your table
contains, but in this case, I've got only
one column and I can just run this update.
So let's actually add one more clause to it,
which is the where clause and this is to just
update the rows that Do you really want to
update so we will be updating only the rows
with product ID equals one. So let's go ahead
and do that. And then I'll just come in and
do a SELECT FROM products quantity has gone
up by 50, it went from 299 to 349. Now one
more thing to realize is actually like you
can, you know, you can specify literal values,
when you are updating, you know, that happens
all the time. Or you can also like specify
a formula, or you can have SQL functions like
replace substring, length, and so on, you
know, you can look at my SQL documentation
to see what kind of functions are available
in this update, like, I just wanted to show
you the syntax, basically, to let you know
that like you can have multiple, you can update
multiple rows at once. In this case, I put
like, values one, two, and three, you know,
you don't have to do one row at a time or
anything. So when you use the end keyword,
and you can say product ID or whatever, call
them in and then a bunch of values to select
the rows that you want. And there are other
ways to do it. But the point being, you can
update multiple records at once. And another
interesting usage is using the case statement,
you know, you can let's say you have a bunch
of update statements, one for product ID equals
one another for product ID equals two and
another for the other product ID values. And
you can combine all that into one UPDATE statement
using a case when then and clause or keyword
basically, in this case, actually, for product
ID equals one, I want to increment the quantity
by 50. And product ID equals two, I want to
increment the quantity by 100, and so on.
So then I've got this similar WHERE clause
are similar to the one that I showed you before,
I'm going to run this you can see the columns
are getting incremental, I'm not going to
go back and check I'm pretty sure that it's
done the right thing. So the next one is basically
when you want to delete records from a table
or purge data from a table, then you can just
use a simple delete statement. And if you
are wanting to delete a particular row, again,
similar to the update, you can use a where
clause to actually like narrow down the data
that you want to delete this particular statement,
which is delete from a table name, and then
where column name equals or the column value.
And you can have multiple filters in here.
So here I don't have the row number three,
I think I deleted it already. Alright, so
let's keep going products three table, I just
wanted to show you it contains a lot more
data than my other table. You can see it contains
data about 5849 rows, I wanted to also show
you this particular parameter MySQL configuration
parameter to basically enable and disable
safe updates. So let's say like if your delete
statement or UPDATE statement is not using
a primary key column in the where clause,
you know, then basically if you enable this
particular parameter, let's say by setting
this one, and then if you run your delete,
you will get like an error code 1175 it mean,
and then it says you're using safe update
mode, etc, etc. It's not leading you to the
run this kind of add delete statements, because
it could be a good cause bad performance.
So if I disable the same thing, and then if
I run the Delete statement, and then just
run a select again, then it should go through
because now the parameter is disabled. And
two more things. One is actually like if you
have a huge table and you want to delete only
a few rows at a time, then you can use the
limit keyword to limit the number of records
that are deleted by the statement, you know,
in this case, because I wanted to delete only
10 rows, let's go ahead and do that. And it
should work just fine. And then if I do a
select, you'll see the difference in the row
count actually, now it's like 5839, before
it was fired four nights. So that's how the
LIMIT clause helps you also in the limit floors,
you can also specify the ORDER BY clause.
It basically sorts the data by these columns,
first by quantity, then by product ID, then
it deletes the top and or 100 or whatever
value you put here, actually. So let's go
ahead and do it and then select again. Yeah,
Kearney, seven D is gone. So the top 10 rows
are gone. And yeah, that's pretty much it.
Actually, those are all a few variations of
update and delete statements. And of course,
there's lots of tangents we can get into but
I will leave that task to you. And I hope
it was useful. And if you have any questions,
let me know in the comments. I'll see you
guys in the next session. MySQL learners.
So in this session, we'll look at SELECT statements,
not just the syntax But also like some ways
you can actually like improve the performance
of your queries, I'm going to be using the
schema called income store to explain about
this SELECT statement in its most simple form
will look like this. So you have the Select
and from keywords and then after the Select,
you specify the Select list, which is the
columns that you want to select. If you specify
a star, or asterik, that actually selects
all the column columns from this table, and
then after the from keyword, you specify the
table names where you want to select the data
from. So if I do a select star from products
underscore three, it's going to return all
the data from products underscore three table.
But do remember that anytime you are using
a star after the Select, or in the Select
list, you're basically querying all the columns
in this table, you don't need to query all
the columns in the table in most of the cases,
so you only like specify the columns that
you need to query. So in this next query,
let's go line by line and see what changes
that have done to this query to make it better.
So let's say I want to select only these columns.
That's why I specified only these columns
in the Select list. In the from clause, I
have specified products underscore three table
very often you will be selecting from multiple
tables, you need to join the tables and then
retrieve useful data out of it. And in the
where clause, you specify all the filters,
or the conditions based on which your data
will be filtered out. So here I am, including
only the data which have quantity less than
25. So this way, I'm able to actually filter
most of the data out of this table, this is
very useful in minimizing the amount of data
that you retrieve from the database. And your
queries are going to be fast as ordered by
is basically going to sort the data that is
retrieved based on the columns that we specify
here. So here, I'm just like ordering by product
name. And of course, like when you're sorting
data, especially when you're sorting a lot
of data, the operation can be expensive, unless
your source buffer size, that is actually
the memory area where the slots happen. Unless
it is sized properly, the operation can be
really slow. So you need to pay attention
to that configuration as well. And I have
this other query, which just goes to show
you that like this is a very simple SELECT
statement. Again, in this select, actually,
I have only the Select keyword and a function,
I'm using the now function. But there are
several other SQL functions that you can use
in the script, for example, I can use the
database function to return the database that
I am actually connected to. And as you can
see, I am actually able to invoke multiple
functions in the same query. So that's pretty
much it. I'll see you guys in the next session.
In this session, I will be teaching about
SQL joints, let's dive straight into the demo,
I will be using a schema called eecom store.
And I'm creating a table first called T one
with one column, the column name is C one,
and I'm inserting these two values in this
table. One and two, I'm creating another table
called T two with a column called C one and
inserting these two values again, into table
D two, one and three. So it's one and two
here and one and three, here, we're going
to go ahead and run a commit to make my changes
permanent. So I'm going to be just creating
these two tables just to show you the records,
D one has one and two, D two as one and three.
Of course, a join is an operation that joins
two tables. And we have all these different
types of joints, we'll go one by one and understand
what they are. So this is the syntax, so select
an a column list that you're selecting. So
we're joining T one and T two. And then we're
specifying the kind of join that we are making.
And then we also have this on keyword. And
then comes the condition on which the table
is joined. So I'm going to go ahead and run
this query and see what happens. As you can
see, this query, this inner join has returned
the value one, so that means actually, so
it returns the values that exist in both the
tables that match. So that's what INNER JOIN
does. So let's just change it to a left to
join, go ahead and run it. Now the left join
is gonna return all the values from your left
to table which is T one. So T one has values
one and two are the rows one and two, and
then T two, it's going to return only the
matching values. And then for this value,
which only exists in table T one, it's going
to return and now and then I'm going to change
it to right join and as you might have guessed
it's going to return all the way Use from
table t to in the places where there is no
matching value, it's going to return a null.
So let's see if that happens. That's what
we expected. So we got all the rows from T
two, and then for three, there is no matching
value and T one, you know, that position has
no value. Now we'll jump quickly to a union.
And then we'll come back to a full join, a
union is basically going to look like this.
So two queries, and then in between, we have
the union keyword, let's see what it returns,
you can see that it's written one, two, and
three. So that's actually the rows from both
the tables, but it's kind of like combined
the data and then smashes them together. And
then you have one, two, and three, and then
let's run the same query with a slight difference.
We'll put union all and then we'll see what
happens. That's written one, two, and one,
three. So that's returned all the data from
both the tables, but except this time, we
have duplicate values, Union gets rid of all
the duplicate values, it's almost like a set
where you have a unique set of data, a union
all returns all the values, including duplicate
data. Jumping back to full join, we don't
have a full join keyword. So rather, we do
full join this way in my sequel. So basically,
you have the similar query where you're joining
T one and T two, a left join first on this,
there's one column that we have, and then
you have another query, again, joining T one
and T two on this, just one column, but then
we are doing a union of these two, and that's
going to return the data from both the tables,
we have one, two, these two are matching,
then for two, there is no matching value.
So it returns and now for three, there is
no matching value in T one, it returns a null
over here. So this is a full joint, that's
basically all the joints, all different types
of joints that you can do in MySQL, I hope
this example was clear. And I'll see you guys
in my next session. All right, my SQL learners.
In this section, we're going to learn about
locks. More specifically, I want to talk about
the isolation level section. So the first
thing is just see what I have here, I have
two terminal sessions. One is in black. The
other one is in slight maroon color. So I'm
actually going to log into the database as
the root user. And I'm going to do the same
thing over here. There you go. I am logged
into my SQL database. So I have a little script
here to create a dummy table called T one.
Okay, so let me show you the SQL script. At
this point, actually, you might not understand
the SQL syntax and so on. But then let me
explain. Briefly, first thing I'm doing is
setting auto commit to zero or commit is basically
a command that you use to save your work.
Basically, the data changes that you're doing
is permanently stored in the database. When
you issue a commit command, in my sequel,
you have this variable called auto commit,
which is turned on by default, meaning all
your commands will be automatically committed.
If you don't turn this off, I want to have
more control over what I'm doing here. So
basically, I am doing an auto commit, disable
first, so and then I'm starting a transaction.
And just to be safe, I'm dropping this table
if I had already created it. So this table
doesn't exist. So it says unknown table. And
the next thing is I'm creating a table called
T one in eecom store schema. And then the
column name is C one. And the data type is
int and its primary key. So and then I'm actually
inserting value, just one row into this table
called p one, right, the one that we just
created. And I issue a commit command, alter
or the alternative to commit is rollback command.
So which basically rolls back rewards the
changes that you just done in that session.
So if I just do a select star from the stable,
then I'm going to see this value, so which
is fine so far. So this is pretty straightforward.
So far, we haven't talked about the isolation
levels. So what I mean by isolation level
is when multiple sessions are trying to modify
or access the same data data, then you need
locking mechanism to make sure the data is
not corrupted, or the database is behaving
in a way that you expect to see how you actually
set isolation levels. And this is the command.
So this is the other session I had opened
show session variables like isolation. So
that shows like the transaction isolation
level is set to read committed. Right. So
this is one of the possible options action.
So this is read committed, and you have read
uncommitted, and you have repetative read,
or repeatable read. And then you have a serializable
value, actually, so let's go one by one, right.
In this session, I already started a transaction.
So I'm going to actually try to update this
value using an update command. So basically,
I am updating the same table, and I'm updating
this column to to where the column value is
currently one, right. So I'm going to do that
the auto commit is turned off. So it's not
committed yet for the start a transaction
over here. And let me run a query against
the same table and just copy and paste the
table name, want to type it, okay, so we see
the value one, which is the previous value.
And if I ran the same query over here, in
this session, I see the value two, because
this is the session where we are modifying
the data, right? So and I can see the changes
before committing in the same session here.
Actually, since the value of this transaction
isolation, or the isolation level is set to
read committed, it is possible only to read
the committed data. In other words, when multiple
sessions are accessing the same data, in this
case, this column right here from this table,
apart from the session that is actually modifying
the data, the other sessions can only see
committed data, any data that is committed
just before this select is executed. So I'm
going to go here and run a commit, and come
back over here and run a select. So now you
see the latest data because that commit happened
before I ran this query. Now let's talk about
read uncommitted isolation, setting actually
freshly log in again, because these things
can get tricky. So every time I want to just
recreate the tables to remove any confusion.
So let's actually log in again, okay, in here,
and I'm actually going to execute the same
script that I showed you before. So just disabling
auto command, starting a transaction, dropping
the stable and recreating it, inserting this
value, and then running the command. So now
here, what we could do is go ahead and update
this value to two. But remember, I haven't
committed this data yet. Let's go to this
session. And here, go ahead and change the
setting to the isolation setting to read uncommitted,
because by default, it is always set to read
committed action. Right. So you can see that
here. So and this is a session level setting.
And you can also change it at global level.
But for the purpose of this demo, we just
need to change it at the session level. So
session level isolation initially read committed,
then I ran the set session transaction, isolation
level, read uncommitted, and then checking
the value again. Now it's changed to read
uncommitted, if I ran a select star from this
table, then I get the value two, and if you
remember that I I only updated the value from
one to two. And you can already see this beta
even though it is not committed over here.
So that is how read uncommitted works. So
there is not much locking going on here. Because
database is now letting the sessions do dirty
reads because one session is able to read
and other sessions changes even before the
commits happen actually, right. So those are
dirty reads. Yes, actually. So let's go on
to the next one. So we have seen read, committed
and read Committed so far. So now let's move
on to repeatable reads action. Right? So exit.
So here I am going to just commit. And I'm
gonna re rerun my initial script just to clear
the table. So drop table and then recreated
insert, value one again, and then commit.
So now, the table is back to how it looked
before. So here, let me log in again. So this
is repeatable read setting, right? So remember
that the default value for this isolation
setting is always read committed. So if I
change it to repeatable read, write, and then
check the value again, then you can see this.
So and again, remember, or show variables
is the command to check the current value.
And then set is the command to set the configuration
right, so I will put all these commands in
like a git GitHub repo file, then you can
actually grab the commands from there, and
then you can try them yourself. Basically,
I'm changing the I'm changing the setting
from read committed to repeatable read, right,
so I'm going to just start a new transaction
over here in here, I'm going to update this
value to two. And over here, I'm going to
run the Select query that we saw before just
selecting everything from this table. And
you see that the value is currently one. And
that makes sense. So let me go ahead and run
commit. And if I ran the same query, again,
I see the value one. And this is the same
as the value that was read before, even though
the data was changed by this other session.
And then committed within this transaction,
the data that we are seeing is the same in
in other terms, basically, we are, we are
reading the same data, or the reads are being
repeated. Right. So that is the third setting.
And the last one is the most strict locking
configuration. So which is called serializable.
So I'm going to, as usual, I'm going to drop
the table and then just recreate them recreated,
inserted value one again, they might come
in. So here, we're going to log in again.
And as usual, the default setting is read
committed, right? So let's check that first,
just to show you, and then I'm going to change
it to serial serializable. So what this means
is, basically, I'm going to start a transaction.
So on the first session, I'm going to run
an update, basically changing the value from
one to two. And here, I'm going to start a
transaction, and I'm going to run a query
on that table. Right. And now this query,
even though it's just a select, select is
just a read, it's not updating, it's not deleting
or doing anything, it's just a read, it is
waiting, because the update is basically updating
this data. And then it's not database, MySQL
databases, not even letting this read or the
Select query from the other session to see
the data. So this is the most strict setting
action. So if I do a commit over here, then
on this other session, you will see that the
Gradius return and it's seeing the latest
value, right. So if I go ahead and run another
select, of course, it's returning the same
thing. But if I try to update this value from
two to three, another update, that is basically
going to wait on the Select, basically this
transaction that is running right now because
the Select again, select is just a read, it
is just reading the data. But still it is
locking that row in the database, and it's
not letting any updates or modifications to
that data. And then you can see that the update
even failed because it waited for some time
and then the timeout value exceeded so we
don't have to go into those details. But I'm
going to try updating now. And here. I'm just
going to exit out of this session, which will
release all the locks. And that will help
the update to go through. And then I can commit
and exit as well, and how you hope it was
clear to you guys. And if you have any questions,
please put it in the comments and reach out
to me somehow I know you can figure it out,
as you guys are next section. Hey, MySQL learners.
So welcome back to this new section of my
MySQL tutorial. So in this video, or in this
section, we're going to talk about locks.
So what are these locks? Right? So let's actually
approach this kind of like logically. So if
you have a database, and if you're the only
person working in this database, then you
basically need not worry about anything, right?
You know what you're doing. So you will insert
data, delete, or update data the way you want.
And there is no one else trying to intervene
or interrupt your work. But unfortunately,
that's not the case. In today's world. If
you think of a busy ecommerce database like
Amazon, then then there's like, a lot going
on on the on those websites. There's like
multiple people browsing is like, a lot of
people buying stuff. There's the people who
are selling stuff on on these websites, they're
updating data relevant to their products.
So that is basically concurrency, right? So
you have many users trying to do something
on this website at the same time, so how do
you manage this concurrency, that's why we
need locks. So if I let everyone work on the
same data at the same time, then there's going
to be a lot of confusion. And we might end
up losing some data. So let me actually show
you a simple example of how that happens.
So I have a table, a product table. So if
you've been following my tutorial, thus far,
we talked about this table called products.
So where we store all the product information,
right. So now, there's a couple of records
over here. And let's say that we have a seller
and a buyer who are working on these records,
especially like this particular record, the
first one, which is a book, and the books,
prizes, this and the quantity, the thing we
didn't have quantity when we talked about
it in my previous sections. But then I added
quantity here. So there's this quantity column.
And there's a there's a seller and buying
buyer interested in this record, let's look
at this, right, so we have sort of like a
time sequence here. So what the seller of
this particular product is trying to do is
he's trying to update the quantity of this
product at nine one, he is adding 60 more
quantity to that product, which is you know,
40 plus 60, which 100. And that's what we
have over here. So then a buyer comes and
he looks at the quantity. And then he basically
wants to order two or these books, that's
100 minus 90 100 minus two, it's 98 and then
you have the quantity 98 over here. So this
happened in a sequence. So but we are worried
about concurrency, right? concurrency is like
when things happen at the same time. But what
if Okay, first the seller comes and then he
reads the quantity of this item. Initially
it was 40 and then buyer comes and he also
sees that the quantity is 40. Right? And at
901. So the first two operations happen at
the same time at nine or one seller comes
in he says I want to update I want to add
60 more quantity, like meaning I have 60 more
books of this title, but then buyer comes
and he says okay, I'm buying two items or
two of these books. So but while you that
he saw before was 40. So 40 minus two is 38.
So he updates the quantity 38. So the seller
updates at 200. But then, because of this
previous look up, the quantity is updated
to 38. due to which this whole thing, this
whole operation is lost. And we end up with
sort of like corrupted data for this quantity
column. So this is a simple example of how
concurrency when not managed well might cause
issue data issues like this. MySQL learners.
So in this video, we are going to look at
basically how table locks works. In the context
of e commerce database, we created a simple
database or schema called the column store.
And we created a bunch of tables or used another
dummy table to explain our transaction isolation
levels. So if you haven't seen my previous
material, go back and check it out. And come
back here. But then yeah, you have four tables
for main tables. And the main table that we
are interested in is products table here.
And in the products table, I inserted a couple
of records. These are dummy records. So I
don't have a front end or application running
over here. So we're just looking at database,
right. So what what's going to happen in this
tutorial is, so we, we're going to basically
simulate a situation where a seller is trying
to update the quantity of the book that he
is selling on this website, which is this
first book actually, the common path to uncommon
success. And then the right now the quantity
of this the quantity available. You know,
for this book is 40, right? So he wants to
update this quantity 200. And also, we'll
have a couple of more users, or buyers, basically
one buyer is trying to buy the same book,
we'll have another buyer Hill, who tried to
buy a different book, which is this book,
tiny habits, and then the same buyer will
also try to browse the website, like of course,
like, we are going to have to imagine a little
bit because I don't have a front end to show
you everything. So let's actually see how
this goes. So first of all, you know basics
first, actually, let's actually turn off the
auto commit. Just so just so actually, we
have more control over what's happening. And
let me do that in all the three sessions I
have open and the first session is the seller
session. The second session is the buyer one
session. And the third session is the buyer
to session, basically. So I'm going to turn
off the auto commit, which is basically a
mechanism that commits automatically if it's
enabled. And I don't want that. So I'm disabling
it. So next is I want to show you the transaction
isolation level. And we talked about it in
my previous session. So right now it's a repeatable
read. And it's the same for all. So we are
going to change that to read committed, because
read committed is isolation is the right isolation
level for OLTP databases. So now let's actually
start with the first seller session. So three
sessions. So the first seller session is going
to update the quantity of this book that he's
interested in or his selling action. But we
are going to take this aggressive approach
and log the whole table. Right. So let's say
the application is returned in a way that
it logs the whole product stable for right.
And then the other session, let's say by one
second session, buyer one comes and he is
going to try to buy two books and and how
actually we're going To do that is by running
an update. So we are basically updating the
products table and we are subtracting the
quantity by two, which means actually the
we are buying two books. And which book is
there in the book? Where are the record where
product ID equals one, right? So if you remember
the data, product ID one is this book, let's
go ahead and run this update in the second
session. And it's going to obviously, wait,
because the table itself has been locked for
right by the seller session, the buyer, one
session is waiting. And let's go to the buyer
to session the buyer to Australia trying to
buy a different book, which book is it this
other book, which is tiny habits book where
product ID equals two. And we're gonna do
that. Of course, even that is hanging or waiting.
And that is actually a little bit crazy, isn't
it. So just sellers trying to update the quantity
of this one record with just one book. And
everything is tanking. And the buyer, too,
was trying to buy a different book, he kind
of gives up. So he moves to a different session.
And instead of buying or trying to buy a book,
he just tries to browse the website, which
is a select query or read query, read a select
query, which is also hanging. So the buyer
too is getting frustrated right now. So you
can see how restricted this kind of sequences.
So if someone's using table logs, that's going
to basically reduce the concurrency of the
operations that can happen in this database.
So that's the main point here in this demo.
Hey, my sequel learners. So in this session,
we are going to take a brief look at row level
locks. In my sequel, I have three sessions,
I'm already connected to my ecommerce database,
MySQL database, and this is how the data looks
now. So we have a products table which holds
you know, this data, only two books now, just
dummy data that I created this, this is the
price and you have the quantity column showing
you how many, how much quantity is left for
each of these books. So the first session
is seller session. The second session is buyer
session, we can call this buyer one session.
And the third session is a buyer to session.
So this is the data. And just for clarity,
actually, I wanted to show you the transaction
isolation setting, which is read committed.
And the auto commit is turned to turned off
basically, it's disabled. So unless I commit
explicitly, my transactions will not be permanent.
So let's actually start with a seller. He's
going on the website or a portal that he has
available to update the inventory of, let's
say the book one, it or the product one, which
is this book. And so he is going to click
some buttons, which is going to translate
to an update statement being executed in this
database, right? So let's say he wants to
increase the number of books available in
the inventory. So that will mean quantity
is going to be increased incremented by 50.
So that's the UPDATE statement. And he's going
to run that update. And we can look at the
buyer one session, let's say buyer one is
trying to buy the same book. And and then,
so he's going to go on the website and then
click on buy now or whatever and then is going
to translate into this UPDATE statement in
the database, choose quantity equals quantity
minus one. So reducing the quantity by one,
meaning he's buying a, buying a book. And
of course, there's going to be, you know,
other statements updating other tables. But
then to keep it simple, I'm just showing you
the product table changes section. So as you
can see, this is going to wait because seller
is updating this particular row action. And
that can be seen using acquittee. On data
locks, so if you're under this greddy, of
course, you can modify this query as per your
needs. But then if you query this, you will
see that there's bunch of sessions and is,
is the lock mode column. And then the table
on which the database on which the locks are
happening the table, so it gives you a lot
of details. So, so if you want to understand
what's going on here. So we have products
table, and then we have ix lock, which is
intention, exclusive lock on the table itself,
meaning like a transaction is about to get
an exclusive lock. And this is at the table
level, but don't get tricked by that. There
is also another row indicating there is a
record level or a row level lock. And, and
that is logging only this data equals one.
So if you remember that UPDATE statement,
we are using product ID. So and data for which
is one, actually, so product ID equals one.
So that's what we are seeing over here. And
if you see here, this buyer session has actually
timed out already, so he's going to attempt
to buy again. So that's how like, you can
actually look at the locking details in this
table. Let's try, let's say like buyer two
comes in at this point. And then he just tries
to browse the inventory on this ecommerce
website. So that would mean a select query
or read query. And he's, he's able to do this
happy reaction. Right. So there is no problem.
So while the rollouts are happening, other
sessions can read this table, they can even
look at the data for the same product. But
they they just cannot buy this book, because
that is being blocked by the seller. So again,
it timed out. So at this point, buyer two
wants to buy a different book, you know, I'm
not able to buy this book, let me try buying
a different book, that's going to translate
to, you know, product ID ID equals two, which
is not being locked by the seller. And then
that update goes through. And at this point,
let's say the seller has completed updating
the inventory. And, of course, if you look
at the data, now, it's going to look different,
because this has been updated to 150. And
of course, this hasn't gone down because buyer,
buyer, one is still in the process of buying
the book, because the commit has not happened
yet in the application. And then if we look
at the data, again, the data has gone down,
or the quantity has gone down, then via two,
let's say wants to buy the first book that
buyer one wanted to buy. At this point, there
are no no locks in this table. Because everyone's
committed, and let's say buyer, who is trying
to buy this, this book, and then he goes through
with that date, and then commits and look
at data. And then the data is changing actually.
So this is how row level log basically allows
for high concurrency. So only the rows which
are logged by your transactions are not available
for these other sessions to modify. Right
So the other records which are not touched
by your transactions are available for updating,
deleting, etc. and all, of course, you can
add new books, that means inserting new records
in this table. So I just wanted to show you
the difference between table level logs and
row level locks. So this session and my previous
session will, will be useful in understanding
that difference. Thank you, I'll see you in
my next session. In this session, we're going
to be talking about deadlocks. And I just
want to show you how deadlocks happen, they
do happen in in a busy ecommerce or B. database
often, so it's good to know what they are.
So it's going to be a very short and sweet
session. So here, we have a couple of sessions
again, so connecting a connected to the same
database has two sessions, two different sessions.
So let's say that we are working with products
table, right. So we have seen the stable before
in my previous sessions. Basically, this table
has information about the products that are
being sold on, you know, an e commerce website.
So we have a couple of records over here,
you know, we're going to first let's say,
you know, I seller comes to actually update
the quantity of this product, basically, let's
say if he wants to increase the quantity by
25. For this first book, this is the command
that he's, you know, that's going to be executed,
you know, whatever buttons he is clicking,
will be translated to an update command like
this. Right. And let's say like a different
person from the same company wants to update
the price of this book, not this book, let's
say we have it the other book, I'm just actually
using the product ID to update the right product,
right. So we have one session where seller,
one is updating the quantity of this item,
we have another session where we are updating
the price of this item. And then if you see
the prices incremented by two, let's say $2.
And this is fine, right? So now we have row
level locks. So this guy is holding a row
level lock on this row. And this guy is holding
a row level lock on this row. So this is fine,
right? So we are operating on two different
records, two different locks are independent
of each other. All good. So now let's say
the same seller, the second person who is
updating with price, wants to update the price
of this other book to actually like he is
actually increasing the price. Again, by $2
of this book, the product ID equals one, which
book, this one right here, let's go ahead
and try to increment the price. By running
this command, you know, he's waiting on waiting
for the lock ECI exclusive lock. And that's
not available, because this seller has not
committed actually is not committed. So let's
actually go back here and, and this seller
at the same time price to update the price
of or quantity of this book. So two sessions
are fighting for pretty much the same resource,
you know, we ended up in a deadlock situation.
So my sequel was smart, smart enough to just
kill the session. Otherwise, we would have
two sessions waiting for each other endlessly.
Right? So here you can see the error code
that is thrown, it says deadlock found when
trying to get locks and try restarting that
transaction. So let's go ahead and query the
products table and see how it looks. You can
see this, this whole transaction was rolled
back. Correct. Both the transactions were
rolled back. There's even this one was rolled
back. So I think that Locke was also killed.
So that's why this this one went through.
If you can see the prices have increased by
$2. right because initially For 1699 and 2039,
and here 8099 and 20 to 39. Okay, so that's
how it works. This is a typical deadlock situation,
I hope this explanation was clear. And I will
see you guys in my next session. All right,
my sequel learners. So in this session, we're
going to talk about clustered indexes. So,
so clustered index is not a different index
type as in, like, you can, you know, directly
create a create a clustered index yourself.
So it is a type of index that, that MySQL
kind of maintains in the, you know, behind
the scenes actually. So, in also your table
data, the data that you insert into your tables
or load into your tables are maintained in
these indexes. indexes only what I mean by
that is, so let's say this is a B tree index,
right, so this is a B tree index. So you have
my sequel, creating this B tree index, as
you load the data into these tables. And then,
you know, in the leaf nodes, what you have
is actually the data, the data that you're
loading into these tables, right? In the clustering,
the sorting is based on the primary key that
you define, or, you know, in this table, actually,
so if you don't define a primary key, MySQL
will automatically pick up a non nullable
index key, what that means is, so let's say
that, in fact, actually, let's jump straight
into the example that I have prepared for
you guys. So so this is my MySQL Workbench.
And, you know, I'll show you this table definition.
So this is called products underscore one.
And it's basically a products table that is
typically used in a ecommerce store. And if
you've been following my lessons, this is
what I've been using, I just changed the name
of the table for, you know, demonstrating
this concept, this clustering, clustered index
concept. So you have all these like columns,
and I'm defining a primary key. Okay, so let's
just start by, you know, I'm just going to
switch to a database called eecom, store our
schema called the econ store, I'm going to
drop, you know, these tables if they exist
already, by any chance. So the table doesn't
exist, which is okay, so I'm going to create
this table, which I just talked about, called
products. And then this table has primary
key in a primary key is product ID. So product
ID is sort of like an integer column. So this
is an auto increment, right? So you don't
even have to provide value for this column,
actually, when you load the data, so you can
just put all this information and load it
and then we are good, MySQL will automatically
increment the value of this column action.
So and then, of course, like I said, like
there is isbm column, which is over here,
sort of leg book iasb. And information if
you are, you know, if you remember your school
days like this, this is be a number attached
with any book, so something like that. So
some kind of ISDN alphanumeric number. So
I'm going to call that like a unique key or
a unique constraint. And let's go ahead and
create the stable and this constraint. So
that was successfully created. And I'm going
to create a procedure, which I can use to
kind of like populate the stable, right, so
don't worry about the details of this procedure.
This is something that I wrote to populate
this table. And then that is successfully
created and change the delimiter back to a
semi colon. And then I'm going to call this
procedure and which is going to throw some
warnings, which is okay with me. As long as
as long as the data gets populated, I'm fine.
So it's going to probably generate some, you
know, load some 6000 plus rows into this table.
So we'll see how much we get this awesome.
So it's actually loading a lot of data. It
seems to be done. So let's go ahead and commit
the data and Now Actually, I'm going to select
the data in this table, right? Just select
all the data, and you will see that the data
by default, or the data is actually sorted
based on the primary key, which is product
ID. And you can see, we know, I haven't like
specified any ordering. So this is, you know,
this is the default ordering of data, right.
And so basically, your table data is sorted
based on your clustered index, which is primary
key over here, because you have the primary
key in the table section. Right. So now the
next thing is actually, I'm going to create
a similar table, which is, you know, so I'm
going to call it products too. But in this
case, I'm going to basically not define a
primary key, I'm still going to have a unique
key called, again, the same thing, you know,
it's isbm, it's a unique key. And let's just
give it a different name, just so we have
kind of like, we have different names for
different constraints. So let's actually go
ahead and create this table. And so this table
is created, I'm going to copy the data from
the first table that you know, where I loaded
a lot of data. So I'm going to copy the data
from that table into this table, right. So
just very simple. And then I'm going to commit,
right, so that's a board 6455 6455 number
of rows inserted into this table. And I'm
going to select all the rows from this table.
And you can see that now, the data is not
sorted by product Id rather it is sorted by
this iasb. And it is sorting based on first
character first, and then Initially, the first
and second characters are the same, then 010
true. And that keeps going 05 and then 090,
a BCD of GE hedge and then having after the
zeros, you know, see one, so it is basically
sorting data based on iasb. And and why is
being because because of the absence of primary
key, it's going to choose this iasb and column,
as are the it's going to choose this non nullable
unique index key, which is based on iasb and
column, right. So it's starting based on this,
but this is actually a terrible, terrible
idea. Because if you're generating random,
alphanumeric strings for iasb. And, you know,
then you're not going to be generating the
string in sort of like an ascending order
or in any type of order, actually. So in that
case, actually, you know, when you're, as
you're inserting data into the stable, this
B tree is going to be created behind the scenes.
And then my sequel, like whatever program
is creating or maintaining this data structure
behind the scenes has to work really, really
hard to manage this Bre B tree index, actually,
right. That's why this is a terrible idea
to have like a you UID or some kind of alphanumeric
string as a primary key actually, or in the
absence of primary key. Well, my sequel is
going to use this this key for clustering.
And again, it is very bad. So keep that in
mind when you're creating tables actually.
Right. So finally, what I'm going to do is
create another table called product three.
And before that, I'm going to show you the
output of this query, which is basically going
to come up empty or no, no, no road rows returned.
All I'm doing is actually checking whether
this index the index with named Jen flushed
index is there in this database, actually.
And then I'm checking the InnoDB tables and
information schema I'm joining in odb tables
and in odb indexes. And I'm checking whether
this index indeed exists, right? Saying it
doesn't exist, which is where the this, this
credit, return no rows, and I'm going to create
this table and this time, I'm not even going
to create the create a unique key. And I'm
going to make all these columns as nullable
columns, you know. So I just want to show
you what happens when you have a scenario
where you're creating a table with all nullable
columns and no primary key index no unique,
not nullable index and you know Then I'm going
to insert data into this table. Again, six,
the 400 plus rows inserted, commit. And then
I'm going to select from this product three
table right now. And when the data comes up,
you can see that there is still some ordering
that's happening. And, you know, we don't
have any of these options primary key or a
not nullable, unique key available, then how
is MySQL able to sort data? What is it using,
so it actually uses a hidden, hidden key actually,
right, a hidden primary key. So if you run
the same query, again, is ready, you can see
that this index has been created on products
three table, which is maintained internally
by my SQL, for just the purpose of clustering
this table, actually. Okay, so that's a lot
of information. I hope you found this useful.
And I will see you guys in my next video.
Hello, my SQL learners. So in this session,
I want to teach you the basics of using explain
or explained plan in MySQL. Alright, so now
let's just let me just show you the table
that I'm going to be working with, I'm going
to be working with that table called products
underscore one. And it's got some net in a
product name, product type price. And if the
product is a book, it will have an ISP a number
attached with it. And then there is a quantity
column. So these are some basic columns that
you would see in an e commerce online store.
So let's get started by just looking at the
indexes of this table. So this basically has
two indexes. One is a primary key index, which
is on the product ID. And the other one is
an index on the iasb and column. And this
is a unique index, actually. So let's get
started by picking a simple query that we
are going to kind of like optimize using explain.
So the query that I'm going to be using is
this. So I'm going to be selecting iasb. And
from this products underscore one table where
product name has cat in it. So the product
name is cat. Okay, so And before I run this
query, I'm going to look at the explained
plan of it. And I'm going to put a slash g
at the end. So I get that we'll put in there
in a readable format. So first of all, it
gives this output, right, and selectors, just
one straights, simple select. That's what
this is showing. But the main thing is we
are working with our this particular row is
referring to this table. And apart from that,
actually, you have all these columns, and
then they are all null right now, like they
don't make much sense apart from this. So
this is a tight column and all means that
it is doing a full table scan. Basically,
MySQL is doing a full table scan, it's scanning
the whole table. And how many rows is that
it's these many rows. And we are using a filter
over here, it gets all those rows and then
it filters the output. And basically a you
know, there's about 600 rows with product
name equals cat, right, so the filtered person
ages like 10%, basically, and then there is
some extra information. Let's go ahead and
create an index on this table. Create index
called, you know, we can give an arbitrary
name. And, and I'm going to create add on
products, one table and the column is product
name, of course. This is the column on which
I'm creating the index. Actually, let's just
go ahead and run the explain again. So this
is the explained plan. And that's how it looks.
So basically, you can see that the Again,
it's pretty much the same kind of output,
but this time, it is also showing some data
for all these columns. So first of all possible
keys column shows like all the indexes that
this query can use. And, and out of which,
like this is the key or index that it is,
you know, it is going to use this particular
execution is going to use, and this is the
key length in bytes actually write the number
of rows that is being scanned in this key,
which is 589. And, you know, since this is
index based, we're not really filtering data,
rather, we're just going to the index and
getting the data. So there is no filtering
over there. Let's actually create another
index, which also includes iasb. And, and
see, like, what happens, actually, we're gonna
create the other index and give it a different
name. So let's go ahead and run the explain
plan again. So now, again, the possible keys
are these two indexes, but it still chooses
to go with this particular index, and the
index, key length is the same, and then grows,
and etc, etc. So there's no filtering that
happened, right? Because we're choosing an
index. So you might be wondering, like, you
know, why it's not using the covering index,
right. So this is supposed to be the covering
index and covering indexes are supposed to
be better than normal, non clustered index
or a secondary index. So you can actually
like, use a format like JSON format to get
more information. So how you can do that is
by just specifying like format equals JSON,
and use the use that. And so that's going
to give you the output in JSON format. And
you can see that the you know, it gives you
a little bit more information as then like
the query cost, you know, this is how much
it's going to cost for my sequel to execute
this query. And this is a representation of
the amount of work MySQL has to do to run
this query actually. So the cost for this
one is 7690, right. And then again, it says
these are the possible keys. And used key
is used key parts is product name, which was
not given over here. And then there is a cost
and for which is a split of where the cost
is going. So you can read my SQL documentation
on all these fields. You know, you might be
wondering why the covering index is not being
used. And we can actually force that index
by using this use index. Syntax or use index
keyword. And then I'm going to put the index
name that I want to force which is this one.
And when I ran it, this ran the explained
plan this time, it shows the cost of this
one is going to be 109 point two seven, you
know in comparison to the previous explain
plan, where the cost is only 76. And this
is why my sequel is going with this particular
plan instead of this guy. Okay, I hope this
session was useful.